hey youtubers it's Charlie so
everybody's freaking out because they
think Anthony Mackie has revealed or
spilled the beans about Mark Ruffalo
being in Captain America Civil War what
happened is is he went on a British
podcast and I'll actually I'll play the
clip of him and talking right here so
you can hear exactly what he said yeah
it's it's really really good and because
it's more of an acting movie than an
action movie I feel like the story is
very concise and interesting and you get
to see Robert Downey jr. and Chris Evans
and Scarlett Johansson and and in every
Mar and Mark Ruffalo and everybody just
do really really good acting you know so
when you see it you'll appreciate it for
the movie it is I think it might be the
first superhero movie that might be up
for Best Picture really it's just him
hyping the movie up he is one of
Marvel's greatest hype men I don't think
there's ever been a film that he's been
in that he hasn't hyped the out of
and yes Civil War is gonna be awesome
but I'm not expecting any Oscars anytime
soon for any comic book movies usually
the type of Oscars the comic book movies
go up for our technical Oscars as in
visual effects costumes things like that
not the marquee Awards like Best
Screenplay Best Director Best Actor you
get the idea but when he's talking about
all the actors being so amazing in the
film he mentions Mark Ruffalo what does
that mean they said that they just
couldn't fit Hulk into Captain America
Civil War well reading between the lines
of what it might mean is that Mark
Ruffalo's in the film but he will not
become the Hulk there will be no code
GREEN the only thing anyone official
from Marvel has said is that Hulk is
gonna have a big storyline over a couple
different films starting with Thor
Ragnarok in ending with infinity war
Mark Ruffalo is an amazing actor you
watch some of his smaller films you get
that sense when he's in a big film like
this there's just not that many
opportunities to get really long scenes
because you can only spend a little time
with each character and previously when
he's been the Hulk character when he
Hulk's out he really just grunts which
is why I think in the future films like
Thor Ragnarok Avengers infinity war
we're going to get talking Hulk in case
you haven't read a lot of Hulk comic
books there have been various personas
like you have the banner persona inside
the Hulk you have the Hulk persona
inside and then sometimes you have a
blend of the two so
comic book writers have always tried to
distinguish different tones depending on
who is speaking are we speaking to
cerebral Hulk are we speaking to The
Hulk persona which is completely taken
over or are we speaking to banner
directly who has just hooked out so even
if it doesn't happen during civil war
you'll see an evolution of the Hulk
character and a lot of it has to do with
the way Banner feels about the Hulk in
the way the Hulk feels about banner
because Mark Ruffalo he's talked about
this a lot in the past but the movies
haven't really addressed it yet the yes
we know Bruce Banner is afraid of the
Hulk afraid of what he's going to do
when he Hulk's out but Ruffalo has also
said that the Hulk is just as afraid of
banner so the thing we haven't seen is
the Hulk side of that we've always seen
banner being afraid of going coke green
there's your Hulk Oscar right there but
because civil war is a Captain America
movie there's so much other stuff going
on I feel like they're not going to
address that but there are a couple ways
you could explain Mark Ruffalo being in
Captain America Civil War without being
the Hulk one they have to explain how he
gets into space for Thor Ragnarok 2 they
could address the Avengers tracking him
down after age of Ultron if you haven't
seen the movie in a while Nick Fury
tells Black Widow we detected a signal
in the Banda sea that's right around
Indonesia just north of Australia so
that's where the Hulk ship crashed at
the end of age of Ultron so he's
somewhere in that part of the world but
those are just the most likely ways let
me know in the comments what do you
think the anthony mackie means when he
talks about Mark Ruffalo being amazing
with the other actors their acting
performances during Captain America
Civil War you kind of have to read
between the lines I don't feel like he's
being outright spoilery but he might be
spoilery in a roundabout way I can see
it now he's hiding out in Indonesia he
sees on a TV in a bar that Captain
America and Iron Man have started
fighting they try to call him up and he
just says new phone who dis and then
after everyone starts tracking down
superheroes he just Jets off the planet
don't want to have to deal with this
I'm gonna call my friend up and
see if I can crash on his pad for a
couple movies I've already mentioned the
rumors of how they're taking Planet Hulk
and breaking up bits of that story and
including it in Thor Ragnarok and
Avengers infinity war that might be the
case I mean it's still a rumor but if
you're looking for a good Hulk comic
book read Planet Hulk through World War
Hulk if you guys didn't see there's a
new daredevil trailer that's coming next
week I'll totally do a video for it
they've already shown a picture of The
Punisher with the skull t-shirt on I
mean it's only peaking above his vest
here you
barely see it but I'm surprised that
they're showing him this this early I
think last year they waited till after
the first week of daredevil being out
before they revealed the red costume
remember daredevil season 2 premieres
the week before Batman vs Superman
so starting around the middle of March
it is gonna be freakin awesome
is there any bonus movie videos you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments in case you guys haven't seen
it I just posted a Deadpool sequel video
all about cable you can click here to
learn all about that and you can click
here to learn all about Harley Quinn in
the Suicide Squad movie thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you